I feel like that whole life is a lie it
is hello everyone I'm Scott Berman hey
I'm Kyle
I'm Alex today we're answering questions
from you guys and Donald supposedly it
was the summer 96 the greatest summer of
my life in which I worked at the
greatest restaurant ever McDonald I
worked there between about the ages of
18 to 20
oh it's full McDonald's in 2005 2006
I worked there from February 2018 to
July 2018 I work the register I was a
cashier and drive-thru I started as a
regular redshirt I ended up as a shift
manager now it's time to answer you guys
questions yeah let's get to it why did
you start working at McDonald's cuz I
was broke and that's it
first job it was down the street from my
house it was really the only job that I
can get at that time so I started
working at McDonald's because I had
actually taken a break from school I was
having a little trouble with depression
and sort of finding out what I wanted to
do with like my degree in careers so I
thought that maybe working in there
would help me gain some work experience
because my parents forced me to at the
time I was really embarrassed you know
to be working McDonald's but now that
I'm 36 I'm looking back it was really
where the good old days my major
concerns were literally french fries and
chicken McNuggets new employees
generally get along does everyone hate
the managers I think we are generally
were McDonald's family we all got along
not anybody goes along do people hate
the managers heck yeah I mean you have a
good manager
like that I want to say overall people
genuinely did get along of course
there's a few people are always pissed
each other off not everyone hated the
managers in fact I actually pretty much
liked my manager a lot customers were a
different story of course do you really
have to charge extra for sauce packets
my McDonald's did not I don't know but I
never would they might have told us to
but the Downs employees aren't
notoriously famous for following the
rules never day I mean people ask me
some extra extra sauce I'll guys I got
some energy we get mad at me if we're
not charging in I don't say I order like
a 10 piece one piece of money like the
sauce vacation on you did you better
yeah you know some people would be like
oh when you watch the commercials they'd
be like like that that's not a dip
chicken in the small fries I don't like
to get too full those things make it
really cool I gotta go make Nuggets and
gotta go french fries I would go for the
iced coffee because it's honestly really
good and that's like what I lived off of
in between shifts fries and probably
like the McChicken or something just
back when they had the spicy make
chicken those those were the good days
I'm gonna go with the Big Mac I'm gonna
make chicken I'm gonna fries I'm gonna
do a McFlurry gorilla cheese burger with
no pickles girl club sandwich put the
bacon on there oh I was waiting for this
one why is the ice cream machine always
broken
why because everybody wants ice cream
audits on the ice cream in there
sometimes it gets clogged up in there so
when you go there and they tell you it's
broken
there's high chance it's not broken it's
just shut up for maintenance that's true
yeah I feel like my whole life is a lie
it is what's really in the grave I don't
know
goggle that honestly disappointment
yeah what's the freshest item on the
menu not frozen
maybe the salads I am also going to say
salad
those that come in a bag hey does your
face actually break out if you work over
the fryer man yes it does that is one of
the reasons why I quit the grease the
heat this was a road thing I actually
never worked over the fryer just keep in
mind that a lot of people who do work at
McDonald's are younger mostly teenagers
young adults so they are probably going
through puberty experiencing some acne
which is like you know pretty normal
honestly how many bites have you seen
this guy we named Santa Claus because he
was a mall Santa he started a physical
fight with three teenagers
he had a track record of really being
like rude and aggressive towards
children
they pushed him back obviously and the
cops were called and yeah that was an
interesting day there I'm just gonna say
a lot that's what I'm gonna answer it's
a lot of points I don't know what it is
about McDonald's but people think like
when they go my balance are going at UFC
events Senor McNuggets be happy and
don't don't hit people in the ball okay
there's the five-second rule apply is
that longer or does they go straight to
trash like what so my job's hell yeah
McDonald I think you know even though
it's a fast-food restaurant everything
is clean anyways you don't have to
expect for them to be like the lowest of
the low if it came to contact with
someone's bare hands or the floor it was
just straight to the trash it's about
you guys might think McDonald's actually
does hold itself accountable if it falls
on the floor you don't serve it
thank you guys for the questions is fun
answering them and like discussing and
seeing our different points of view so
these questions are crazy thank you so
much people for listening to us
McDonald's employees telling you about
the greatest restaurant in the history
of the world
McDonald's either way working they're
working on McDonald's honestly one of my
favorite jobs and the environment was
flying raw and the same age thing so for
us are just like good times if you're a
kid a teen like looking to work at
McDonald's
I wouldn't say worry all that much cuz
there's a high chance you'll actually
have some fun it's not all horror
stories it's it's a pretty decent job in
my opinion
[Music]
[Applause]